what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and right now there is
just a ton of talk going on about black
panther wakanda forever rightfully so
people are wondering who exactly is
going to be the next black panther and
there's even a lot of talk of doctor
doom possibly being behind the war
between atlantis and wakanda which would
be an insanely cool cameo of course but
i do think there are going to be other
cameos in wakanda forever that could
also set up some pretty big things in
the mcu like the x-men and i am
specifically talking about the mutant
storm and for those of you who know the
story of t'challa and storm you know why
but i will be specifically talking about
why storm and other cameos are possible
and why some are actually very likely in
wakanda forever and we could have
actually already seen a storm easter egg
in the teaser trailer for wakanda
forever which of course we'll talk about
in this video and i actually think that
we could see a ton of cameos from old
characters and from some new characters
as well and the reason that i think we
could see so many cameos is because of
t'challa's funeral his funeral of course
is going to be sad but like we saw in
the trailer it looks like it is going to
be somewhat of a celebration in wakanda
and whether it is going to be sad or a
celebration or both i would expect some
avengers to show up now i'm sure not all
of the avengers will be invited and i'm
sure that most of the world won't be
invited but there are some characters
that i would expect to show up like
bucky who spent a lot of time in wakanda
from the end of civil war to avengers
infinity war who eventually would go on
to become the white wolf i would assume
that bucky shows up at the funeral and i
think it would actually be kind of weird
if he didn't but there are some
characters who most likely would not
show up to the funeral these are
characters like the guardians of the
galaxy and thor spider-man ant-man
hawkeye these are all characters that
had contact with t'challa but didn't
have really a relationship with him they
either fought with him in avengers
in-game or fought against him in captain
america's civil war but also an end game
everybody fought together but it was
kind of a mess so they didn't really
have time to talk but here are the
characters that could show up and like i
said there could be some old ones but
i'm expecting some new ones as well now
right away i am not expecting captain
america to show up but there has been a
lot of talk of chris evans returning
although he has denied these rumors i do
think it would be cool if he did a quick
little cameo just to show up to show his
love for t'challa but i'll group captain
america with the less likely people to
show up however his two best friends i
think should show up to the funeral
bucky of course and then sam they all
fought together in wakanda and of course
they all made amends after civil war
bucky even went back to wakanda it would
make sense if these two showed up to
show their respect then we have bruce
banner the hulk now the hulk is
appearing in she-hulk so we know
marvel's not afraid to put the hulk in
other shows or movies and he was a big
part of the fight in avengers infinity
war at wakanda plus not to mention he
was a brilliant scientist and he clearly
saw how advanced wakanda was and how
smart shuri was and i'm sure he'd love
to go visit wakanda again and of course
pay his respects and then i would
actually expect war machine to show up
and not only because he fought alongside
of t'challa and avengers infinity war in
wakanda but also as kind of a
representation of america showing their
support for wakanda he's very high up in
the military and he was a friend it just
makes sense for him to show up all
around now speaking of the x-men and
mutants in wakanda forever obviously
neymar in the comics is a mutant he's
half mutant half atlantean but in fact
one of neymar's nicknames from marvel
comics is the first mutant and now of
course the first mutant in the mcu is
miss marvel kamala khan so mutants are
arriving which is why i think that storm
could actually make her mcu debut in
wakanda forever showing up for
t'challa's funeral now for those of you
who read the comics you know that
storm's origin story has been retconned
but marvel does consider her new retcon
story to be her actual origin story
where when she is 12 years old she is
rescued by t'challa the two of them
quickly fall in love with each other and
eventually the two of them would go on
to get married so yes the mutant storm
does become the queen of wakanda and
from there her story is actually really
cool she has to decide between being the
queen of wakanda and an x-men however
she says no i won't decide i will do
both and she even comes in contact with
the black panther god bast now obviously
unfortunately since chadwick boseman has
passed away and t'challa is not going to
be a character in the mcu anymore i
don't think any of this is going to
happen which is fine we've had plenty of
x-men movies with storm where it doesn't
mention t'challa at all however i do
think they should keep this connection
because i think it would be meaningful
now i don't think that storm and
t'challa were married at any point in
time at the mcu but i do think that they
could keep storm's origin the same where
when she's 12 years old t'challa
actually rescues her they don't have to
fall in love but they could have been
great friends or heck maybe at some
point in time they were in love but for
whatever reason it didn't last
regardless i think they should include
this connection in the mcu and if they
do that means that she should show up
for the funeral and since right now it
seems they're introducing mutants in
different projects and namor is a mutant
it kind of seems like the perfect
opportunity to just throw storm in there
and there may have already been a little
hint at that in the trailer now in
storm's original backstory she is a
descendant from a long line of african
witch priestesses with white hair and
blue eyes and a natural gift for sorcery
well in the black panther wakanda
forever teaser trailer that we got we
can actually see that some people in the
teaser trailer during the ceremony for
t'challa have white hair perhaps this
person could be from the same tribe that
storm's mother was from and storm's
mother was actually the princess of the
tribe perhaps this is a hint that some
other tribes that storm might be from
could show up to the funeral now i would
love for them to kind of hit the nail on
the head and just straight up say this
is storm this is aurora but i think
marvel studios might be a little bit
more subtle just having a woman show up
with white hair saying something along
the lines of i'll miss you friend and
just hint at it and maybe not address
her by name but i do really hope that
this could be a cameo that we could get
and again based off of the story in the
comics and the future of the mcu
introducing the mutants and the x-men i
think it's a perfect opportunity now i
do also think that neymar is going to
show up for the funeral neymar and
wakanda have a very long history with
each other and they're not always
enemies namor isn't really a villain
he's more of an anti-hero but given the
long history between wakanda and
atlantis and the comics i'm sure that's
going to somewhat transfer over to the
mcu i'm sure wakanda and the atlanteans
aren't just going to go to war with each
other randomly or after their first
meeting i'm sure they've met before in
the mcu in fact in the trailer we saw
namor as a kid on land it could have
been in wakanda so i'm sure they have a
relationship already and since the
atlanteans are kind of like the
wakandans they try to stay secretive
they seclude themselves from the world
and of course they live underwater i'm
sure they've shared many things in
common including vibranium that is
probably in the ocean i'm assuming that
namor has probably met king t'challa
even if he met him before he was king
and i actually think this could be the
first time we see him in the film in the
beginning at the funeral he shows up to
pay his respect but i'm sure it's going
to be somewhat controversial because of
the history between wakanda and atlantis
this is probably going to be where the
tension starts namor shows up for the
funeral wakandans don't really like that
and then something else happens and the
two of them just go to war with each
other now like i mentioned before
there's a rumor going around that dr
doom could actually be behind everything
that happens in wakanda forever because
he wants to start a war between atlantis
and wakanda so he himself can get some
vibranium now having said that i don't
think we're actually going to see doom
in the movie i think we'll probably hear
a name drop or perhaps he'll show up in
a post-credits scene but i would
absolutely freak out if victor von doom
showed up for the funeral of t'challa i
do not think this is going to happen but
the possibilities for a ton of cameos
are very very real so i am definitely
expecting some cameos we'll have to see
who it is but i am really hoping for
storm it just makes sense but hey let me
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below if you love marvel
don't forget to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all the latest news
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you